a video of Mike Tyson is going viral
tonight it allegedly shows the former
heavyweight champion repeatedly punching
a fellow Airline passenger before a
flight his Camp says that passenger
provoked him ABC's Rina Roy has the
story
dramatic moments caught on camera
allegedly showing Mike Tyson pummeling a
fellow passenger on a plane
TMZ obtaining the video taken on board a
JetBlue flight set to take off from San
Francisco to Miami Wednesday night the
passengers had visibly injured shortly
before another clip appears to show that
same passenger making a scene one row
behind the former heavyweight champion
Mike Tyson bro
Mike Tyson there are reports that the
unidentified passenger may have been
intoxicated
in a statement Tyson's reps saying
unfortunately Mr Tyson had an incident
on a flight with an aggressive passenger
who began harassing him and threw a
water bottle at him while he was in his
seat Tyson then got off the plane before
takeoff according to police both Tyson
and the passenger were detained before
being released before the flight Tyson
appeared at this 420 event in San
Francisco and was on his way to Miami to
speak at a Cannabis Conference he was
later spotted in Miami seemingly All
Smiles in a photo posted by pro
wrestling Legend Ric Flair
Tyson has a long history with law
enforcement dating back to Childhood he
also spent time in prison for in 1991.
oh my God you guys are [ __ ] up why the
[ __ ] did you bring that up but you
didn't bring anyone but you but did you
you didn't bring the fact that the other
passenger has a rap sheet as well a rap
cheat is fraud a rap cheat of uh having
um selling selling drugs a rap sheet of
all those [ __ ] he did 15 years inside
and 20 years at 15 months inside and 20
months inside but you're going to talk
about Good Old might huh the one being
harassed you're gonna talk about that
Melvin is his name the other dude you
wanna you wanna bring back his spec you
guys you guys are garbage for that
garbage I imagine there's why they bring
up that is because when it's a violent
offense and two uh it's Mike Tyson who's
the focal point
garbage garbage straight garbage but
anyways
um
um yeah like who said that yeah was you
that said that uh play them games and
win super prize then and that's what it
is you went to you went to be behind
[ __ ] Mike Tyson and harass the man
and you went before you boarded the
plane you was harassing him you boarded
a plane you harass him and you threw a
boxer
you got a beat down out of it
I'm really I'm really disappointed you
can get snuffed
leave [ __ ] alone leave people
alone she
go ahead do not go ahead yeah
Mike Tyson oh my God the number of times
I've seen people
you think to yourself sometimes my God
why is Josh simpia
has a bodyguard he knows how to fight
because you will have complete Goobers
walk up to him and try to test him
being intoxicated anybody that's in
fighting or whatever you have complete
idiots trying to test their might in a
Mortal Kombat [ __ ] death your mind like
you have to break some Ruby you have to
and that's that's what happens you try
to nag these [ __ ] and then what
happened happens you're stupid you know
damn well what's gonna happen then you
make you got your buddy [ __ ] filming
it that's stupid you're crazy and you
stupid and you deserve everything that
happened to you for what reason would
you throw a water bottle at somebody
when the person is not doing nothing
apparently they took a picture together
when he wanted something so he's like
sure and then he just kept going after
him you know part of me thinks that Mike
Tyson deserves it for flying jet blue
another part of me thinks that as far as
the passenger is concerned like yo
you know I think people see a celebrity
and think they're just entitled to
everything that celebrities and Mike was
more than patient we've seen on numerous
occasions where people try to test bikes
there was even incident where Mike was
at a comedy show and somebody pulled out
a [ __ ] weapon on him and you saw Mike
just sitting there chilling
all right
there you go
yeah and you see Mike keep calm and then
the dude comes in he gives him a hug and
then he ends up disarming the dude in
the weapon like you see he's chill about
a lot of stuff so you have to really
push some buttons to get someone to step
and sometimes people only look at the
retaliation really look at what started
how much does the person have to endure
you threw a water bottle at somebody's
heading you're belligerent towards them
it's like bruh that's crazy and you
sitting behind them too which means I
can't even have my back to you because
you acting crazy that's crazy you out
here filming it I'm thinking like yo
this [ __ ] gonna do something
weird
crazy right and it looks don't it sound
like don't it look like a whole bait you
got the [ __ ] filming and then
you nagging me so I I gotta stay patient
but now you do a bottle
yeah listen people will really be doing
the most sometimes and until the
fortunate because Mike is most likely
going to face the lawsuit and lose some
money over this it's not normal behavior
it's not normal behavior
and you shouldn't have to sit there and
take it because let's be honest if this
was anybody throwing a water bottle at
your siblings
about some physical right
what would you do
it's not in the context of a show it's
not a context you're on a [ __ ] plane
just moving about
somebody's throwing [ __ ] at you yelling
at you putting the camera in your face
it's like ref get the [ __ ] up off me and
he was patient and he waited and the
person didn't stop that's crazy oh no
maybe
I'm Different maybe maybe it's
just the minority people I could never
see myself doing that even to the most
crazy celebrity I've ever known in my
life leave people alone
could you see yourself no of course not
what are you even talking about like
that's crazy hey Mike can we get a
picture sure oh belligerent for like
whoa can you guys attempt
but you touched on a really good subject
with the fact that people really
feel like they're entitled yeah I follow
you I pay for your patreon I pay for
this I pay for that I went to see your
show I subscribed by this it doesn't
give you the right
to harass people
it doesn't give you the right to take
pictures of me and my kids whenever the
[ __ ] you want doesn't give you the right
to take but yeah but you're in a public
eye
no
I'm in the entertainment business
it doesn't mean that I want my
everything out there for everything to
everybody to watch there's a reason why
he doesn't have a
he doesn't have an account in social
media and there's a reason why I don't
talk about all my [ __ ] like that I don't
post my daily life
most of the [ __ ] I post on Instagram is
repost from people that saw me somewhere
but I'm not gonna go and post my family
and this and that and no
that's me that's my me time
I share enough with y'all that's what
you get
that you feel that you need to nag
people if you want to say what's up say
what's up
if you want to say that you appreciate
the word perfect
harass a [ __ ] I mean yeah but
you're a comedian you should take jokes
you're not and you're not working right
now neither am I
I'm harassing anybody it's wrong period
I think as far as you know doing the
whole
being known and being seen by people you
know people say it's part of the game
it's part of the thing sure you know you
can certainly say that doesn't mean it's
right it doesn't mean that you as an
individual have to engage in that right
so if you're watching this and maybe you
feel like you've done something like
that just don't do it in the future
that's all I'm not going to say like oh
I'm I'm entitled to never having that
happen because I'm expecting it which is
why I limit my interactions with people
on my accessibility to people I know
where I go I go to specific events I
travel in a certain way I wear certain
attire to like look Incognito and I'm on
my business because I know I can't
expect that
but if you're out there and you're just
seeing somebody like yeah you know go
say what's up after that like don't be
just hanging around trying to do all
this extra stuff following the person
they don't for Mike himself like I don't
know maybe it's because I've seen him in
a lot of podcasts and I've seen him on a
lot of shows and I see a lot of the work
that he's been doing but it seems like
he's really turned over a leaf and from
the violent self that we saw for a long
time it seems like it's clearly changed
but
you know that part of him is still there
and if you push somebody enough and
throw them and attack them I'm not
surprised when that [ __ ] comes out so to
me I watch this and I have to stop to
myself like
it's unfortunate because this is going
to cost him a lot of money and nobody
should be able to be put in that kind of
situation because at the end of the day
the other dude instigated the whole
thing that's my thoughts
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you